tutti ragazzi e benvenuto questo video
sono fa vigente oggi siamo su lei disse
comparto è il salto tutorial perché io
so giocare alle cose senza saperlo spero
che devo fare un quadro un ritratto una
questo devo fare ritratto di una persona
o di un qualcosa non lo so in 90 secondi
devo farlo ea me non basterebbe credo 90
anni per fare un quadro però va be good
luck perfetto si parte da chi cazzo è
amico mio sei bella o 90 secondi per
fare un ritratto due si può fare una
cosa decente ragazzi a farti scherzi ok
io sono un fenomeno che disegni no
seriamente la gamba altri scherzi
voi mi conoscete come la persona che sa
disegnare meglio mi stupisco di me
stesso
ecco una goccia d'acqua a parte gli
scherzi intanto sono già passati 45
secondi e non ho fatto un cazzo
bellissimo era madonne che è mite non so
non so usare i colori normali l'ho pure
mixarli ci manca solo quello come cazzo
affaccia in 90 secondi a queste cose ma
spiegatemelo o mio dio no termica so sto
facendo non è poi la maglietta maglietta
una maglietta perché sembra che la sua
maglietta mi guardi in modo bruttissimo
ma il cazzo dai cazzo che sta accadendo
vabbè ma dio mio il nerone dov'è il nero
ecco questo gli occhi gli occhi la bocca
già fatta cos'è cos'è o mio dio è sta
roba c'è una nuda devo farli l'agi già
anche duri segnali la g no fermi un
attimo che ci prova come si fa a star o
lo so messo la metà del tempo solo
scegliere il colore pensate tema ce
l'hai le ossa zia fammi capire qual è il
senso di questo gioco spiegato non vi
prego chi già si vede che stai mai di
hamburger del mcdonald determinati ok ok
allora di fisico c'è di fisico c'è
finito il tempo ma almeno il fisico più
o meno dai cazzo che manca poco vai male
dai facciamo la nostra rossa uguale più
bella rossa perché c'è nei pantaloni in
testa ma dio mio
gli occhi verdi io ti sei ragazze
bellissima l'anima anima e corpo a fare
story genio mi dai un dollaro come si
svalutano le alle opere degli artisti
madonna tre anni varrà milioni se non
hai capito niente
hai mai pensato di fare la controfigura
di dumbo nato lo chiedo e non si sa
faccia in testa una scopa ma che uomo è
l'inizio cos'è oh mio dio amica che
occhio storto ragazzi ragazze ecco erba
della scopa più o meno dai apprezzi
apprezziamo lo sforzo in pratica di devo
fare il cos'è sta roba è un perfetto per
adesso no no no no no il tempo il tempo
il tempo il tempo cazzo come faccio a
farli 90 seconda dai non è possibile che
quanta lo sa cos'è sta roba le braccia
nere le braccia nere non importa è
uguale e lui due dollari ed è già
qualcosa dai ragazzi se qualcuno di voi
vuole farsi un
è un ritratto o mio dio una balena se
qualcuno li vuoi interessata a farsi un
ritratto cose leggere i contatti faccio
io bello mi chiami uscito anche bene se
io non so come come ho fatto a non
scoprire questo gioco prima è
impossibile cioè ragazzi meglio di
photoshop in segno di fotoritocchi
chiedete a me
guarda che baffi alla pierre visiva si
può avere solo chi si chiama piero che è
il bar madonna questo è uscito bene fate
scherzi questo mi sta uscendo bene se
non mi perdo adesso
ok che è come faccio a fare il bianco
che già bianca la tela di mortacci l'onu
bene così ma da ragazzi è bellissimo è
un capolavoro d'arte moderna do rovinato
alla fine di mortacci loro contengono 6
il solito le isole di sole non faccio
l'ho fatto l'ho fatto bene e poi è
questo e questo vale almeno 200.000
dollari se non è possibile
due li prendi per il culo commesso delle
ore a fare chi sei obama non è razzismo
ma devo farlo un proprio nero questa eco
perfetto da perché siamo tutti gli
orecchi e così madonna che è successo è
colpa di chernobyl
una roba deformazioni dovute a
radiazioni proprio una roba bellissimo
diventato bravino e ti telefono a casa
oh mio dio c'è l'occhio storpio rai dai
capelli capelli capelli veloce veloce
cazzo dai dai dai dai dai dai che cos'è
e bellissimo zero è uguale cazzo ma 9 ma
[ __ ] dopo una giornata di duro
lavoro guadagnato il 5 dollari perché ho
fatto dei ritratti di merda che roba che
questo non ce la facciamo
ragazzi questo era uguale però è questo
non potete dire un ca è uguale perfetto
ragazzi il primo giorno è andato a
vedere il prossimo che riesca bello
amico mio sei un figo madonna hiroshima
a destra parte chiara grigia non bianca
poi manca la faccia manca tutto si si eh
lui è così cosa ho fatto e la valigetta
così questa cosa ho fatto
si può tornare indietro e vabbè è uscito
così un dollaro e la madonna con il
conte idraulico mi fate capire cosa
dovrei fare come come si fa a fare
dracula quelle sono le orecchie sembra
sembra un uomo che sta risultando
e bellissimo
[Musica]
trasformiamo un nuovo che sta esultando
in dracula bello altobello capelli neri
altissimo macro e sexy o mio dio non sa
le gambe cazzo non c'ha le gambe
quest'uomo adesso c'è la rega io ho
visto sto male giuro che sto male
bellissimo e bellissimo 3 dollari
ho incassato il mondo nella mia vita ho
giocato a diversa roba dove si disegna
ma mai così bello è stato un gioco e ai
guardalinee precisione madonna vasa la
cosa più ridicola ghazi è bellissimo ed
è lui che è lui e lui lo prende vita la
mia arte prende vita la che non c'è la
mano di mancarmi mancavano rossa lo sta
facendo la rosa arancione uguale ecco
cos'è un dollaro ma [ __ ] 5 dollari
anche oggi giorno due ragazzi mi ci
stiamo spingendo oltre questo è il
capolavoro della della vita arce io
questo lo manderei a di prezzo è la vita
arte contemporanea si denota un leggero
tocco di post impressionismo anche con
una leggera sfumatura ispirazione a
gauguin in questo ritratto dove
l'artista ha voluto esplicitare i
lineamenti del volto esponendole nella
loro più reale bellezza tra i quali
sicuramente il naso ma ragazzi mi sta
prendendo veramente bene sto gioco non è
una droga a un certo punto io me lo
sogno la notte lo so già io mi e gia
ragazzi un simpson da scalando il tè
veloce veloce cazzo da che gli manca una
mano di manca la mano il collo
ecco la storia qua quattro donne sono
ricco sfondato non ci posso credere è
più bello di me quando mi sveglio la
mattina
credo si sicuro ragazzi per la prima
volta ho finito prima del tempo cioè
fantastico 0 dollari apre apprezzo lo
stesso vorrei capire una cosa minchia
sei tu dov'eri quando avevo bisogno di
te ne la mia vita dove eri uomo è una
cosa atroce ma lo voglio fare assoluta
per così è un bernoccolo quello si usa
fare fa bello il bernoccolo è la cosa
più bella di tutto il disegno lega
bellissimo quanto mi dai per il berna
quella che vale 2 dollari solo quello
che questa ragazza come le persone
esposte a radiazioni vengono è un
pompelmo esatto è la stessa cosa vale
per lui che tra frames
dico della madonna e poi c'è lui che le
vince tutte accordo ragazzi faccio
l'ultima che poi ecco leggermente
spostato a sinistra ma me ne fotto va
bene uguale l'ombra ci sono riusciti a
fare il colore dell'ombra cioè amatemi
cos'è sembra che abbia la barba ragazzi
capelli sono la vita è più che roll così
dai guardatemi mi sposerei per questi
ritratti 4 dollari ma sei pazzo mi
sbrana vivo se non lo faccio uguale
ragazzi proprio come sapete darmi 4
dollari per quello proprio amico mio c'è
un alieno al posto del naso ma mi deve
sganciare l'assegno ragazzi voglio
l'assegno sembra molto più alieno questo
che lui più incazzoso lo voglio picasso
zoe è mica uguale e lui se non mi sborsa
i contanti non me ne vado voglio
diventare milionario comunque come 0 ma
come il kolossal qual è il tuo problema
al cervello avete presente la scena in
titanic quando lei si spoglia e nuda le
dice ritrae ni come una delle donne più
belle per lui è la stessa cosa
e l'apoteosi del sexy io non ho mai
visto una cosa più bella di quest'uomo
c'ha anche il ma trango che sta finendo
dai che sta venendo un capolavoro non mi
puoi far venire tempo così cosa c'è in
testa peli pubici noi ragazzi seriamente
i calzini cazzo gli mancano i calzini
vabbè a posto così i ragazzi che belle
un dall solo un ometto su una boy band e
lo voglio dentro lui lo voglio de
assolutamente sembra mia nonna incazzata
o mio dio aveva un pene una volta
quest'uomo è diventato nero e l'ha
tenuto così dato perché c'è batman
dietro
[Musica]
ecco ragazzi spero che abbiate
apprezzato la mia bravura dal mio
talento
ruby l'episodio spero che il video vi
sia presunto spero che sia servito la
lezione perché questa una lezione d'arte
contemporanea quindi ragazzi servito è
piaciuto classe dosso fumetto mi piace
anche a pagina di facebook come la di
video tratte la descrizione sono sempre
discreti se non si lavora diventati
artisti lo diventerete iscrivetevi e
impari lette molte più cose su come fare
di tratti veri da un vero artista
noi ci rivediamo in un prossimo video
bene ragazzi